[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur lcp l'émission on
parle cuisine mais aussi alimentation
agriculture écologie politique avec les
bonnes recettes pour bien vivre ce
confinement vous le voyez sur ce plateau
nous sommes masqué c'est le protocole
sanitaire qui a été arrêté par
l'assemblée mais on va pouvoir tout à
leur enlever les masses pour déguster
les bons petits plats de chez françoise
alors avec moi pour présenter cette
émission
jean-pierre montaner bonjour jean pierre
bonjour bojic beaux jours sarah l'aeri
bonjour ça valérie bonjour secrétaire
d'état chargée de la jeunesse et de
l'engagement un ministère qui vous
correspond très bien puisque du haut de
vos 31 ans
vous avez déjà une longue carrière
politique une ascension fulgurante
depuis vos débuts à l'ump c'était en
2010 en 2015 on vous retrouve sur la
liste de bruno retailleau aux régionales
mais après c'est 100% modem jusqu'à en
devenir tout récemment la porte parole
c'est sous cette bannière que vous avez
été élu en 2010 est député de
loire-atlantique et c'est une
circonscription qui a très très
largement inspiré le magnet d'urgente et
exactement au menu un plat qui jongle
avec les couleurs du lieu jaune au
beurre blanc même si visuellement c'est
plutôt la verse dans notre assiette et
on dessert encore une spécialité de
votre région
un gâteau nantais dans le dos ou des
plats des ravages de la publicité sur la
malbouffe
un enfant sur six est obèse le
gouvernement doit-il intervenir dans les
pieds dans le plat ce n'est pas du
gâteau confinement rime souvent avec
galère pour les jeunes le gouvernement
doit-il les aider davantage allez on
passe à table tout de suite ses cuisines
et confidentiel
sarra el aissi vous n'aimez pas les
clichés 1 qui accompagnent votre
ascension politique fulgurante et je le
comprends
à table aussi vous contourner les
poncifs contenu de vos origines
marocaines on salivait déjà avec
brigitte à l'idée de déguster un tajine
aux pruneaux une pastilla eh bien on se
contentera d'un plat moins exotique qui
révèle votre attachement viscéral
gustatif j'allais dire à votre fief
politique la loire atlantique un lieu
jaune cuisiner au beurre blanc leur
beurre blanc c'est une source comme son
nom l indique pas et c'est un totem
aussi de la gastronomie française alors
sahara pourquoi le beurre blanc plutôt
que la chermoula pour plusieurs raisons
parce que l'on attend une marinade
marocaine c'est tout à fait ce qui me
met une marinade marocaine
il se trouve que moi j'ai grandi
entourée de plein de repas j'ai grandi
en cuisine puisque mon beau père et ma
mère avait des restaurants et donc j'ai
grandi dans cette agitation de ses
fourneaux de ces odeurs qui se marient
qui se conjuguent
mais chez moi il y a j'aime les plats
partager ceux où vous savez votre votre
grand mère a toujours la meilleure
recette que celui que vous mangez au
restaurant il souhaite que le beurre
blanc
c'est ce cas là c'est grâce est de votre
grand-mère pas exactement non même ma
grand mère ça aurait été les pastillas
les grillades
par contre cette mon territoire ce
territoire de coeur qui est le mien
celui où je suis tombée amoureuse parce
que la cuisine c'est histoire d'amour
mais ça crée des émotions sacrés ça
laisse des souvenirs
eh bien c'est ce beurre blanc alors on
n'imagine pas comme ça on n'imagine pas
en sauce on l'imaginé au plus tôt dior
est ce que je vais prendre une sauce
avec du beurre on peut se poser la
question mais en réalité c'est toute une
finesse c'est une fille n'est ce pas
c'est quoi la particularité du beurre
blanc c'est c'était qui libre entre
entre le vin blanc et le vinaigre et le
sel c'est équilibre très très malin et
il ya plusieurs techniques pour cuisiner
mais vous vous savez le faire bien sûr
et puis j'ai en plus j'adore ça pour y a
plusieurs que plusieurs techniques la
première d'être effectivement du
vinaigre la douceur du beurre qui doit
être salée puis
itron dedans non pas du tout moi pas de
citron et au tout début en fait je
voulais utiliser la largeur de manière
la plus orthodoxe le beurre blanc avec
du sel on rajoute du sel donc du beurre
du beurre doux sauf que c'est pas du
tout la méthode nantaise méthodes
dentelle c'est un peu de beurre doux
beaucoup de beurre demi sel
principalement à la fleur de sel de
guérande
quitte à en profiter et puis franchement
c'est sans modération puisque après sur
le sur le poisson vous pouvez en
rajouter s'ils créent un peu de croquant
fait quand ça arrive dans la boue
n'était pas d'échalotes dedans ainsi si
au tout début c'est vraiment de
l'échalote qui est comme moi j'aime bien
quand elle est même très content alors
ça vous laisse et l'échalote au fond au
fond de la marmite très longtemps
franchement faut c'est simple la
gourmandise donc vous prendre il faut
prendre le temps de le faire
vous mettez de l'échalote est encore
mieux ça c'est la petite le petit
plaisir personnel
mais les chéneaux de gries l'échalote
grise pour faire le le beurre blanc est
meilleur parce que la laque ou à un
groupe de caractère oui et vous faites
vous laisser vraiment content parce que
j'ai peur que vous soyez déçu on en
droit d'enlever les masques barre des
masses pour nous tous mais j'attendais
que ça n'entrait ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que cette summer blanc et super
parce qu'il est très brillant et très
très lisse oui et c'est tout c'est tout
l'exercice
c'est comment met on était aussi un oui
mais c'est une chose qui est plutôt qui
paie pas ce qu'il vient qui vient ce
c'est super bon oui il est très bon de
placer du bon beurre blanc et délicieux
vous qui le faites parce que souvent le
beurre blanc ne fait pas bien dans les
cuisines
on fait surtout dans les restaurants
vous avez une petite astuce pour le pôle
ne pas le rater parce qu'on peut rater
le beurre blanc ça pouvait tourner non
oui ça peut ne pas prendre on s'est
loupé qui votera sincèrement l'astuce
c'est de faire son échalotes avant et
moi c'est ce que je fais je prends
vraiment le temps de faire d'avoir un
confit d'échalotes déjà prêt avec avec
du vin blanc plutôt du muscadet et du
vinaigre blanc et quand ces prêts du
coup tu vas l'esprit vraiment qu'à faire
tombeur blanc et à le faire prendre que
tu remets ton confit d'échalotes tu mets
moi je mets trois quarts de beurre demi
sel est un tout petit peu de beurre doux
même si c'est vrai je vous sais pas là
tu sais pas la vraie vraie méthode mais
ça permet de trouver le remède
donne une autre astuce qui est de chefs
cette fois-ci inratable quasiment il
faut que le beurre soit très très froid
oui effectivement le silver est très
très froid il faut pas qu'il commence à
être un peu pommade et un peu ramollir
donc le beurre soit très froid pour et
ensuite tourner tourner tourner alors
vous avez demandé du poisson et vous
êtes une des rares invités à venir dans
politique à table et a demandé du
poisson c'est majoritairement de la
viande
vous avez un attachement particulier
pour la pêche et la wii mais parce que
je pêche parce que je pèse parce que
parce que j'ai grandi avec un indé un
grand père qui pêchait en mer et j'ai
gardé cet amour de ces temps de partage
donc j'ai pêché avec mon frère j'ai
pêché avec maison plus principalement en
mer au maroc ou sur le littoral à olemps
est à la traîne aux lancers ont lancé
depuis depuis la rive donc aux lancers
longs baroque au pôle nord j'ai pas eu
l'occasion de pêcher au groupe même si
j'adorerais mais j'ai pas peur c'est
juste l'occasion qui ne s'est pas
présenté mais vous savez quand vous
pêchez et que vous êtes en mer ces
dépêches avec de la houle c'est de la
pêche qui est vivante donc en fait quand
vous tenez votre canne à pêche vous
sentez si vous êtes toujours en train de
vous demander si est-ce que ça touche ou
est ce que c'est
est ce que c'est les courants et en
sportif aux sportifs mais c'est génial
mais c'est quoi comme un poisson au
plein plein plein de poissons différents
et en plus j'ai commencé pour tous à
être tout à fait honnête non pas aux
lancers mais à la touche parce que parce
que la can et un essai en mer en mer et
ensuite ensuite pas du coup j'ai gardé
cette j'ai découvert en arrivant à
nantes la pêche en eau douce et c'est là
où sur la vilaine j'ai la chance d'avoir
un 1
un petit pantin de coeur où on pêche
principalement en tout cas j'aime pêcher
l'anguille l'anguille away we parce que
c'est je sais ma ligne comme empêche
l'anguille c'est pas une espèce protégée
non maintenant ça va aller on peut
pêcher des anguilles on peut mais
certainement que dans des endroits des
endroits autorisés
puisque la pêche à l'anguille est
effectivement protégés donc il ya des
règles à respecter
c'est une page qui suit est difficile
anguilles parce que ça donne des
d'écouté cesser la violence et c'est ça
qui est amusant c'est une pêche qui est
quand même assez sportive et après quand
vous avez cette anguille de langui
grillé voilà c'était j'allais dire c'est
pas que lui dit que la pêche ou ensuite
vous vous aimez bien consommer les
poissons dans ces choses là évidemment
c'est ça glisse c'est un peu plus bas à
tout le monde même pas languir oui mais
moi j'avoue j'adore ça ça va la préparer
mais en plus on a tous en tête les
vidéos et les émissions de maïté mais
bon ça mais on a tous à venir vers le
service et dé maintenance rénovation
était ça me paraît très vieux non c'est
s'aider rediffusion traversé je croise a
très bien vieilli ça travaille ça a
traversé les générations et aujourd'hui
on trouve beaucoup de choses en terme de
vidéo sur internet il suffit d'être
curieux il suffit de le vouloir
et moi j'aime ses cuisines qui sont qui
sont vivantes qui s'attache à nos
territoires à nos vies est qui et qui ne
se démode pas parce que ça crée
aujourd'hui je le disais au début mais
c'est vrai que vous avez des origines
marocaines
on s'attendait à ce que vous nous
parliez des saveurs des goûts du maroc
parce qu'on a beaucoup là-bas des épices
quels sont les souvenirs qui vous reste
du maroc et est ce que vous mangez
encore de la cuisine marocaine nous en
cuisine et même jean cuisine et j'en ai
gardé beaucoup et c'est toute cette
conjugaison sauvez moi j'aime les
cuisines j'aime notre cuisine enfin
danthez au dpi des pays de la loire
j'aime la cuisine française mais j'aime
toutes les cuisines parce que ce qui
m'importe c'est le sel l'émotion ce que
ça provoque en toi et donc j'adore les
cuisines du monde
je suis je peux faire des fajitas je
sais cuisiner ça j'aime faire quand on
voyage le seul jeu qu'on a en revenant
c'est de revenir avec des petits
ingrédients essayer de reproduire et
donc là actuellement je suis sur le
petit le poulet tikka masala donc
j'essaye de 1 vient c'est au maroc que
sinon ça veut dire c'est marrant mais
c'est super bon on avait appris à la
cuisine bien mais j'essaye et j'essaye
essais je trouve ça assez
après il ya de quoi aller en maroquin il
ya un plat que ma grand-mère faisait et
que j'aime beaucoup c'est tout
simplement le poulet
un tajine avec du poulet des pommes de
terre du citron et des olives vertes et
c'est implacable accusé marc est un bon
tajine laisser enchanter longtemps et
oui c'est un tajine qui mijote c'est des
pommes de terre fraîches c'est plutôt un
poulet fermier et surtout du citron très
très confus et c'est des plats qui se
partagent et en fait c'est ça que j'aime
c'est les plats ou où vous êtes nombreux
à partager ou on reproche dans le plat
principal pour se resservir parce que
patrick hobbit en revanche pas non
malheureusement
voilà vous sentez dans me donne
exactement tout l'appel que ça peut que
ça peut mettre mes mais c'est qu'un
temps et je crois qu'on finira par
dépasser spurs eux qu'ovide ya pas de
raison enfin c'est quand on est français
rien ne résiste ou qu'on y arrivera on y
arrivera collectivement mais ces moments
là qui sont importants vous m'avez l'air
très très forte en cuisinant à voir si
vous êtes vraiment incollable sur le
quiz est alors puisque vous êtes très
forte en beurre 1
première question premier quiz laquelle
de ces préparations est un beurre
attention un subtil de nuances cuisiner
et non à rebaptiser tout ça fait partie
du grand livre de la cuisine de la
gastronomie française à beurre maître
d'hôtel béber marchande 20 c beurre
d'escargot des beurs de zahia vous
connaissez sans doute toutes ces
appellations donc laquelle de ces
préparations est un beurre cuisiner et
non aromatisées eh bien je vais être
absolument honnête avec vous je ne sais
pas pour une raison pour une raison
toute simple c'est que c'est moi je
cuisine et je mens je les produits tels
qu'ils viennent tels qu'ils sont comme
ça à l'instinct je vous dirai peut-être
le berre maître d'hôtel mais sans grande
conviction puisque puisque dans le
beurre je le mange le cuisine le met
dans une casserole n'est exactement
plutôt netter dire je ne sais pas c'est
une qualité ou si c'était le beurre
marchand de vin le borgne vin est
effectivement cuisiner il est chauffé
alors que les autres recettes
c'est un beurre froid qui est aromatisée
voilà donc le beurre marchand de vin et
un beurre aromatisés passe à la cuisine
marocaine maintenant deuxième grise
quels sont les trois ingrédients qui
sont indispensables dans cette cuisine
alors à l'huile d'argan b le fenugrec
c'est les pétales de rose d
la pâte d'anchois donc il y a trois
ingrédients qui sont indispensables dans
ces quatre que nous vous proposons là
alors il ya plus à plusieurs éléments
moi je vois l'huile d'argan qu'on peut
manger mais qu'on peut également
utiliser sur le corps cette union de
craie riche dans les cheveux ça c'est
très très très très bon le jeu voit pas
très bien les bleus fenugrec les pétales
de roses la pâte d'anchois la pètent
dans le choix j'en mange beaucoup à la
maison mais comme ça de mémoire ça doit
pas être très marocain puisque c'est
plutôt mon beau père italien qui en
faisait beaucoup et faisait des anchois
marinés
donc je dirais que la patte d'un foie ne
n'est pas le débat le marocain va c'est
gagner c'était bien l'ingrédient qu'il
ne fallait pas revenir sarah doublement
raison parce que c'est un produit très
utilisées par la cuisine italienne dont
bravo double bravo pour ce deuxième quds
vous êtes très fortes aussi en cuisine
italienne votre beau-père avait des
restaurants c'est ça exactement
restaurant italien donc moi j'ai grandi
avec des bons vins des pâtes fraîches
des fromages en sardaigne beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de tournages du
pecorino du parmesan évidemment mais pas
que et surtout la particularité de la
cuisine la cuisine sarde
il ya un plat moi qui me touche parce
qu'on le mange avec du coup le papa de
mon beau-père qui malheureusement est
parti depuis mais c'est la ricotta avec
du miel le maintenant ça de la ricotta
frêche en sardaigne mais vraiment
superbe
brillante vous rajoutez un peu de miel
dessus vous mettez ça sur une tartine ça
se mange tout seul et c'est trés quotas
on peut là on peut la cuisine est une
salade vache ou de chèvre deux matchs
principalement c'est ce qu'ils se
gardent le mieux après vous pouvez en
avoir effectivement de chef mais elle a
un goût un peu plus prononcée et pour le
matin c'est vrai que celles de vaches et
un peu plus douce mais si vous faites
par exemple des petits traviole avec de
la ricotta et des épinards c'est hyper
facile à faire ça c'est parce que c'est
quelle est votre plat signature si un
jour on va dîner chez vous ces marocains
c'est très bien ces fusions a peut-être
un mélange de tout ça ça va avec côte
avec eux ça va dépendre de ce que j'ai
dans mon frigo c'est aussi c'est aussi
certains considéraient alors oui je
alors ça peut ça va de concilier les
restes partir d'un plat principal qui
devient une entrée
de mélanger aussi les goûts les goûts
non pas sur le même plat mais dans la
manière d'accompagner le repas est
profondément c'est ce qui va faire
plaisir à l'autre parce que c'est ce qui
compte le plus dans le dimanche en chez
vous à midi
est-ce qu'on parlait politique comment
ça se passait les repas en famille tout
l auberge espagnole ce qui est l'auberge
espagnole parce que le dimanche c'était
le seul jour où le restaurant n'était
pas ouvert et donc c'était les seuls
c'étaient les seuls moments où on ne
mangeait pas avant l'ouverture du
service donc et ça beaucoup de d'enfants
de restaurateurs ou de restaurateurs
mais reconnaît connaissent ce temps que
tu manges avant que tu manges après le
service
il dimanche eh bien c'était c'est grand
c'est grand moment de coupe barbecue ces
moments de de poissons aux celtes et ses
poissons concon mes connaissances et
délicieux bien sûr ma et et du gros sel
en dessous beaucoup de gros sel vous
mettez un beau brochet fin poisson celui
que vous avez peut-être du poisson frais
vous le compléter vous mettez du célèbre
couteau ou météo vous route c'est ça un
peu dire et on casse à l'hôtel laïco
exactement est comme ça vu de
l'extérieur aux îles ça va être hyper
salée en fait pas du tout et d'une
tendresse ccc accueilli comme un peu à
l'étouffée finalement seigle c'est
exactement ça cuit sous le sel et vous
le sortez vous vous levez un filet vous
mettez simplement un filet d'huile
d'olive un peu de fleur de sel et vous
dégustez ça aussi simplement et en fait
j'aime ces plats simples mais qui sont
extrêmement serrés stoehr avait une
clientèle internationale marocaine aussi
les marocains aiment bien la chair il
aime bien des jeunes et beaucoup
beaucoup
il y avait un peu des deux mais oui
beaucoup qui aimait ses places et plats
italiens mais de cuisine traditionnelle
j'ai vu évidemment patrick mignola d'en
lancer dans l'autre émission qui parlait
de boutargue effet d'amancey séquelles
sa vie c'est un produit italien mais
c'est un produit pour les connaisseurs
et donc on faisait de la boutargue dont
faisait aussi beaucoup de pâtes fraîches
et beaucoup de cuisine
encore une fois simple mais bonne est en
fait un truc tout un truc tout ça dépend
du produit et finalement c'est
actuellement des spaghettis à la
bolognaise salaires simple comme ça mais
c'est délicieux quand c'est bien
cuisiner et vous en mangez jusqu'à finir
après votre assiette avait vraiment le
goût le bon produit vous vous allez vous
le sentiment
et vous aimez ça choisir vos fruits et
légumes moi j'ai un marché de coeur qui
est le marché de talensac à nantes où le
dimanche c'est un marché en fait couvert
ses 1 5 fois et puis à l'extérieur le
dimanche il ya également des producteurs
parce que en fait moi je vais acheter
non pas en partant d'une recette mais je
vais acheter par rapport à ce que je
vais voir ce que je vais croiser comme
produit et puis c'est l'odeur les
saisons et les odeurs est en réalité
vous passez vous trouvez des belles
tomates à que vous pouvez trouver du jeu
je pousse mais nous on a beaucoup de
matches on a beaucoup maintenant
unitaire de maraîchage donc on a
beaucoup de beaucoup de légumes que vous
croisez après une bonne viande ou un bon
poisson apprend on à la petite tradition
de aller à 11h vous achetez vous est-il
des huîtres un bon plan ou un petit
muscadet ce que le très vite et on a le
droit parce que c'est celle axes la
culture de cette place nantaise
eh bien on arrive avec avec c'est avec
ces huîtres on s'installe en terrasse
puis vous avez le cafetier qui arrive
qui sert le bon muscadet très frais et
puis on ouvre aussi six vitres avant
d'entrer à la maison alors ces moments
là qui comptent en france le déjeuner
occupent une large place est notamment
en politique alors on vous a demandé de
réfléchir à un souvenir politique autour
d'un repas et c'est ce qu'on appelle la
brève de comptoir alors sarah ilahiri je
le disais tout à l'heure vous avez déjà
une longue carrière politique est
forcément beaucoup des jeux des
politiques
alors est-ce qu'il y en a un qui faisait
revenu en mémoire oui le le seul ou en
réalité j'ai mangé je me suis fait
cuisiner à la fois un futur c'est vrai
les accepter c'était avec marc fesneau
ah c'était avec marc fesneau et il était
venu des relations avec le parlement
aujourd'hui tout à fait qu ministre en
charge des relations que le parlement et
qui a été mon président de groupe
parlementaire puisque j'étais député
jusqu'à il ya il ya quelques il ya
quelques mois avant de rentrer au
gouvernement et marque donc vient du
loir-et-cher en voiture parce que il se
trouve que ma fédération modem de mon
territoire souhaite que je prenne une
présidence d'intérim parce qu'on a eu
une démission en cours de route et à ce
moment là le marc marc raynaud et le
secrétaire général du parti et donc il
vient voir ce qui se passe dans notre
fédération et puis accompagner cette
transition est là donc on fait notre
première réunion mais y met pour quand
même que j'apprenne à la connaître
et là on voit mon badine et donc après
la première réunion de notre fédération
on va dîner on va dîner dans un dans un
lieu nantais en face en fait de de
l'opéra nantais qui est assez connue qui
sert très tard et je me souviens très
bien ce qu'on a mangé ce qu'on a mangé
des tartares et c'est lorsqu'un colis de
viande au poisson viande viande tartare
préparer comme on aime c'est à dire
qu'il est préparé devant le client et
vous choisissez donc vous vraiment vous
mettez plus icg avec moi j'adore avec
beaucoup de cadres et et donc pas
d'oignons crus je suis pas très fan en
fait des tubes cru mais beaucoup de
beaucoup de câpres un tout petit peu de
sauce barbecue alors que je sais que
c'est pas c'est pas le plus orthodoxe
dans la cuisine mais moi j'aime bien
parce que ça je trouve ça relève un
petit peu le goût et il prépare le
tartare avec un deuxième saladier pleins
de glace ont donc en fait votre art un
art il est très très frais il est très
bon il est vraiment très bon et c'est un
tartare couper au couteau
donc vous avez vraiment le goût le goût
de la de la viande fraîche ça a été
conclue ziv ce dîner vous avez emporté
la fédération et bien oui c'est comme ça
avec le modem à a continué c'est ce
restaurant c'est ça au lieu d'en tête
que ça pulse et la cigale c'est un lieu
qui est connue qui est certes très très
tard en fait et qui sert toute la
journée donc à quel que soit le moment
où vous arrivez vous pouvez manger avant
le confinement de la cuisine et de la
cuisine et à essayer de comprendre qui
j'étais
quelles étaient mes engagements et quel
était mon histoire et ce jour là a
commencé l'histoire qu'est la mienne
plus particulièrement avec avec le modem
ma famille politique et marc fesneau
on poursuit avec notre assiette qui dit
beaucoup effectivement notre politique
menée en matière d'alimentation
d'écologie et même de sociologie c'est
le dessous des plats
[Musique]
les ravages de la malbouffe un enfant
sur six est obèse en france et 35 % des
étudiants reconnaissent avoir une
alimentation déséquilibrée selon une
étude de la mutuelle étudiante et médias
alors pourquoi mangent-ils aussi mal des
éléments de réponse avec ce sujet d'
hélène bonduelle des céréales fondant au
chocolat des gâteaux des jus de fruits
sucrés des fast-foods impossible ou
presque d'échapper à ces images dans les
coupures pubs des programmes les plus
regardés par les enfants un matraquage
publicitaire sur des produits trop salés
trop sucrés trop gras régulièrement
dénoncé par les associations de
consommateurs
on a fait les heures des centaines
d'heures de visionnage des publicités à
destination des enfants
résultat 90 % des produits promus sont d
ou e c'est à dire la classe la pire dans
le code de nutrition donc il faut que ce
soit le législateur qui interviennent
ils qu'ils disent ben écoute et fait la
promotion de tous les produits
alimentaires que vous voulez mais pas
des plus déséquilibrés en visant les
enfants car cette publicité intensive et
ciblée n'est pas sans conséquence elles
influencent les comportements
alimentaires des plus jeunes
selon santé publique france un enfant
sur six est en surpoids ou obèse et
visiblement d'autorégulation des
industriels que le gouvernement appelait
de ses voeux ne suffit pas et maintenant
et je plaide pour sa l'urgent d'encadrer
par la loi des objectifs que l'on
assigne à tout l'agro industrie le
député en sait quelque chose
en février 2019 il avait déposé une
proposition de loi pour lutter contre
les dangers de la malbouffe
la proposition était assez simple c'est
effectivement de supprimer complètement
la publicité à destination des enfants
on voit qu'aujourd'hui elle est
interdite uniquement sur les programmes
jeunesse sur les chaînes publiques par
la loi gattolin mais on voit bien que
c'est pas là que les enfants sont devant
les écrans ils sont devant les écrans
moment
souvent où ils prennent leur repas avec
leurs parents donc au moment où on voit
le matraquage massif de ses publicités
et on sait que les enfants sont
notamment les prescripteurs des courses
qui sont faits après avec les parents
peine perdue la majorité a supprimé son
article concernant l'interdiction de la
publicité
la ministre de l'ecologie barbara pompe
il y travaille bien sur un texte qui
envisage de bannir des écrans télé les
produits nocifs mais quelles en sont les
contours et surtout est-ce uniquement à
la télévision qu'il faut s'attaquer
cette spécialiste du marketing
alimentaire en doute la télé ça reste
l'essentiel des investissements
publicitaires des entreprises
agroalimentaires mais il ya une part
croissante sur internet est en fait les
adolescents surtout regarde beaucoup
plus les écrans sur internet que la télé
la publicité sur internet
elle est souvent beaucoup plus immersive
beaucoup plus engageante et là ils ont
une attention qui est maintenu
donc c'est encore plus d'effet sur leur
comportement que quand ils sont passifs
devant la télé
d'autant qu'en cette période de
confinement les plus jeunes sont
susceptibles de passer plus de temps
devant les écrans et de fait devant ses
publicités pour des produits loin d'être
équilibrés
sarah ilahiri on vient de voir ce sujet
un enfant sur six qui est obèse et on
voit bien ce lien entre finalement la
publicité et la malbouffe finalement
l'obésité est ce qu'il faudrait à
nouveau légiférer pour interdire ces
publicités moi je pense que nous avons
besoin d'accompagner nos enfants à mieux
manger à affaire évidemment plus de
sport c'est toute une éducation est en
fait la manière de se nourrir c'est la
manière qu'ont choisi pour vivre pour
trouver sa place dans la société
je crois pas qu'il faut alors je suis
âgée j'ai été l'initiateur je crois pas
qu'il faut légiférer sur tout par contre
il faut que on éduque à mieux manger
qu'on apprenne à nos enfants
l'importance des produits l'important ce
sera prêt quand même à légiférer pour
interdire par exemple des publicités sur
des véhicules qui sont trop lourds ou
trop polluants finalement pourquoi on
interdirait pas des publicités qui voit
là
on dénutris work sent pas bon c'est
dangereux finalement pour la santé de
nos enfants ce qu'on fait pour protéger
les enfants c'est déjà en fait il ya
déjà des choses on part pas de rien
c'est toute la protection sur les temps
pendant qu'ils aient un programme
jeunesse parlant pas la télé comme vous
avez un programme jeunesse 15 minutes
avant quinze minutes après il n'y a pas
de publicité de malbouffe en tant que
tel mais oui mais ce que ça disent les
spécialistes et que les enfants ils
regardent aussi des programmes avec la
jeunesse et c'est là où on les matraques
de pub et on voit bien le lien je sais
pas ce que vous aviez conscience à ce
point entre la le regarder des pubs est
allé acheter les produits les plus les
plus terribles pour la pour l'obésité ce
lien ce lien il est là il est clair il
existe mais moi vous savez je fais
partie de ceux qui croient que la
manière dont on mange c'est la manière
dont choisi de vivre et donc il faut
plus que jamais investir toute cette
tout ce champ du mieux manger de comme
en cuisine comment on prend sa vie
quasiment en main et là se pose pas
beaucoup de sujet c'est comment on mange
rapidement et bien comme on mange
rapidement dehors et de manière
équilibrée et donc évidemment se pose la
question de la publicité mais ce n'est
pas l'alpha et l'oméga de la lutte
contre l'obésité de nos jeunes c'est
évidemment illusion mais il y en a aussi
ses sur les réseaux sociaux
donc on est confronté à ces publicités
là qui est effectivement en train d'
achat après il entraîne l'achat et c'est
là où nous avons plus c'est c'est tout
le débat sur le consom'acteur nous avons
besoin que nos enfants que nous que
notre jeunesse et plus largement que les
parents et toutes les informations
nécessaires et qu'il puisse lire c'est
pour ça qu'à la question dénutris corps
les plus accessible possible justement
ça qui est certain c'est les cas liés
aux industries agroalimentaires
proposez-nous des produits avec dénutris
corps qui soit bon pour la santé mais
c'est le cas en fait c'est déjà le cas
nous avons voté à l'époque j'étais
encore à l'assemblée nationale nous
avons voté par exemple le fait
d'alourdir aujourd'hui la taxation sur
les produits extrêmement sucrés dans les
boissons dans les boissons gazeuses
pourquoi parce qu'on sait que il faut
diminuer notre habitude au sucre parce
qu'en réalité en fait on boit extrême
des produits extrêmement sucré et on se
rend même pas compte parce qu'on s'est
habitué et donc plus ils baissaient la
quantité de sucre
- le poids le poids financier sur leurs
produits étaient importants et ça il ya
évidemment le combat du législateur
qu'il faut mener
mais je dis simplement que interdire une
publicité n'est pas jeudi c'est un des
outils mais ce n'est pas le seul élu
c'est à l'école c'est à la faculté c'est
à quel moment finalement de la vie pour
ces jeunes tout au long de la vie c'est
pour ça que à l'école d'el mode est
vraiment dès le plus jeune âge il faut
apprendre à partager à cuisiner les
temps de la cantine c'est des temps
collectifs où il faut apprendre et
comprendre ce qu'on mange et donc
prendre le temps nécessaire pour
s'approprier les les produits mieux les
comprendre on sait que le repas est
extrêmement important est libre et il
est d'autant plus important que avec
notre majorité
on a par exemple mis les petits
déjeuners obligatoire dans les endroits
les plus les plus en difficulté parce
qu'on sait que la manière dont ange a
des conséquences aussi sur notre qualité
d'apprentissage c'est une question
sociale aussi on sait les ce sont
souvent les plus pauvres qui mange le
moins bien pour eux parce que d'abord
pour des raisons financières mais aussi
parce que on veut faire plaisir aux
enfants parce qu'ils ont des
frustrations à droite donc on leur
autorise le coca cola à table on leur
donne des bonbons chocolatés
c'est aussi ça et ça s'est compliqué en
termes d'éducation de deux de faire
passer ses messages les plus important
c'est que il ne faudra jamais céder à
l'idée qu'il faut être riche pour bien
manger et ça on a deux on a deux
chantiers extrêmement important pour
bien manger très bien mangé ah oui petit
prix aujourd'hui on peut très bien
manger du bio même décennie même du bio
même d en fait il ya plusieurs chemins
les premiers c'est d'abord des produits
les plus locaux possibles parce qu'ils
sont de qualité et ils sont en réalité
moins cher c'est des produits de saison
parce que quand on mange de saison alors
il ya de la quantité sur les étals etc
des produits il faut apprendre à aussi
utiliser des produits non transformés
est en fait la vraie bataille elle est
là vous savez très bien que quand un
produit est transformé il y a beaucoup
de sel
il y a beaucoup de sucre en grande
majorité d'un grande majorité des cas et
donc pour bien manger à petit prix il
faut apprendre à cuisiner et donc
prendre ce temps et c'est là où
l'éducation est importante pour les
parents et pour les enfants
on peut cuisiner très rapidement et en
même temps des produits bons est simple
et facile si on cuisine alors on
s'approprie et quand vous disiez pour
les familles des fois les plus modestes
ont fait plaisir avec un chocolat ou une
confiserie c'est vrai mais ce n'est pas
c'est pas une question de moyens
je crois que le moment de partage qu'en
cuisine et pour le coup moi c'est les
moments qui sont importants c'est des
moments où on a des temps de familles
qui sont importants et c'est là où on
peut
gagner cette bataille d'une meilleure
nutrition mais dites-nous vous vous êtes
amatrice de malbouffe
ça vous arrive de déguster un hamburger
j'imagine de temps en temps oui oui mais
en fait oui comme comme beaucoup la
toule équilibre n'est pas sur
l'interdiction du burger ou pas du
burger
c'est l' équilibre entre tous c'est
manger un burger sans citer de marque
une fois par mois parce que c'est un
moment de plaisir
alors oui il faut continuer à pouvoir le
faire par contre il faut que le reste de
la semaine le reste du mois vous avez
manger équilibré et vous avez également
fait du sport c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement est extrêmement mobilisés
sur les 5 fruits et légumes par jour
c'est votre cas je crois que vous mangez
des fruits toute la journée alors
effectivement je sers comme on dit ça
mais ça mais c'est vrai moi j'ai pris
toute la journée c'est pour éviter de
grignoter d'autres d'autres confiseries
ou d'autres gourmandises
mais il m'arrive comme comme beaucoup
aussi de me faire plaisir et de
m'arrêter dans un drive et prendre un
bon burger parce que j'en ai envie
par contre je fais attention le reste du
temps c'est ce que font beaucoup
d'étudiants on a vu un chiffre qui est
alarmant 33%
un étudiant sur trois dit mal manger
est-ce que vous là aussi vous avez des
préconisations des mesures pour essayer
d'encourager d'aidé souvent puisqu'on
disait aussi que c'était un problème
social ces étudiants à mieux manger et à
davantage intégrer cette notion dans
leur alimentation
oui en fait déjà commencé de manière
très très concrètes nos étudiants sont
c'est une population qui en réalité
réinvente le monde devrait cesser nos
jeunes qui changent notre manière de
manger de consommer d'acheter c'est eux
qui ont qui nous bousculent en réalité
beaucoup plus vite que nous notre
énergie notre génération et donc pour
les accompagner pour les pour répondre à
une question financière d'abord c'est
tous les repas par exemple à un euro
dans les restaurants universitaires
pourquoi parce que dans ces restaurants
de cuisine collective
alors on peut faire attention à
léquilibre l' équilibre alimentaire et
donc d'accompagner les papilles de nos
dons jour dans ses restaurants et points
d'eau
jamais de mémoire ne s'était pas
toujours très très bon et franchement
c'est de c'est de mieux en mieux et
c'est mon logement j'ai beaucoup manger
et c'est ça peut être très très bon et
c'est aussi tout l'engagement qui est
fait aujourd'hui dans les cantines même
pour les plus jeunes c'est génération
après génération c'est là où il y a
évidemment les sujets d'interdiction
depuis lothar souvent déserté la cantine
pour aller manger un gars que c'est ça
le problème
donc il faut c'est comme ça c'est quand
vous avez 16 ans et que vous voulez
le les éviter le temps de la cantine pas
que mais la question c'est est ce qu'on
sait faire et ce qu'on sait faire un
grec équilibrer la réponse est oui
il suffit d'avoir une bonne viande une
viande de qualité sans avec un le moins
de gras possible ça dépend de la sauce
que vous mettez dans vos services
et si votre pain il est frais et il n'y
a pas de conservateurs un grec ça peut
être très très bon ça dépend de la
manière dont les cuisines et alors on a
vu pendant le confinement en fait les
enfants étaient avec les parents ils ont
plutôt mieux manger mais ils ont aussi
plus regarder la télévision
donc en fait ils ont grignoté est-ce que
vous avez changé vos habitudes
alimentaires pendant le confinement j'ai
beaucoup plus qu ce débat sur le premier
confinement je vous avoue parce que ceux
de le premier confinement j'ai été
confiné chez moi à nantes et donc du
coup en visio mai mais à la maison et
donc j'ai beaucoup beaucoup cuisiner et
j'avoue j'ai essayé plein de choses
parce que j'ai la chance d'avoir un
petit potager
par exemple j'ai fait des frites de
butternut alors plus ça parce qu'en fait
j'ai eu beaucoup de courage
d'abord je voudrais donc j'en ai eu des
cas ces grands la friteuse non pas du
tout bah oui parce que sinon ça au four
était trop gras exactement au fond j'ai
pris un saladier j'ai coupé ma butternut
en frites j'ai fait une soupe et de la
purée optionnel est vraiment beaucoup
mais vous mettez un peu après car un peu
d'huile d'olive vous mélangez tout le
tout dans un saladier
vous mettez un film de pâtisserie en
fait juste attention que les frites soit
bien bienne est allé hop 40 minutes au
four et vous avez des frites délicieuse
d'ailleurs j'ai encore la photo dans mon
téléphone tellement c'était bon et je me
suis amusé pour refaire du coup après
une putin parce que je parlais de
cuisine interne est à ressasser le
canadien s'amène vous avez séjourné au
coeur y est ce que vous avez gardé des
souvenirs uda petit culinaire alors
dites moi c'est quoi la bombe à la
poutine tu vas y franchement vous n'avez
plus fin quand vous l'avez terminé c'est
c'est en réalité c'est des frites que
vous mangez dans un dans un bol
principalement ou 1 ou encore nés avec
de la sauce brune qui ressemble un peu
un fond de veau ou une sauce fromage
cherche c'est au choix
alors les traditionnels c'est que ça
avec un peu de fromage qui fait chaque
match week
mais c'est parce que je ne sais pas
c'est quoi le nom de ce fromage
parce que il est surtout pas fromage nom
est d'accord et il l'appelle même la
balle de la tête
couic couic complet mais en bouche en
fait ça fait du bruit dans vos oreilles
et elles font pas mal bouffe la routine
on voit la superbe les mythes un petit
peu pneus
mais un moment maman aussi cuisine la
cuisine plaisir c'est là où je pense
qu'il faut il faut vraiment qu'on est
chacun les moyens de bien équilibrer et
de bien savoir à quel moment on peut se
faire plaisir un peu plus largement et
pas être dans la culpabilité mais
surtout avoir tous les outils pour pour
être pour faire attention à sa santé
allez on va parler des enjeux du
confinement un peu de politique je vous
propose qu'on met à présent les pieds
dans le plat en ces temps de crise
sanitaire et social les élans de
solidarité se multiplient à travers le
pays pour venir en aide aux plus démunis
et aux plus vulnérables exemple
aujourd'hui à saint denis où nathalie
gilbert a suivi des jeunes de
l'association cévennes dream qui
distribue aux habitants du quartier et
bien des invendus de marché de rungis
regarder bonjour je m'appelle condé
sillage les 27 fin juillet du bien
bonjour je m'appelle chimène j'ai 24 ans
et travaille dans la communication
l'appel access et 26 ans travaille
[Musique]
ne vous y trompez pas ce n'est pas un
nouveau groupe de musique mais bien des
jeunes qui ont décidé de se bouger pour
aider les eaux avant le premier
confinement il fut de la médiation
culturelle et aujourd'hui ils se sont
reconvertis dans l'aide alimentaire dans
ce quartier de saint denis qui
connaissent bien le leur tous les
membres fondateurs et tous les bénévoles
pour la plupart habitent des bâtiments
s'attend que c'est l'ensemble de ces
immeubles
depuis quelques mois ces jeunes ont
changé leurs habitudes du week-end ce
matin c'est déballage des cartons
d'invendus du marché de rungis tout
chargé dans un camion de tomates
poivrons banal clément chine bat déjà on
a vu qu'il y avait quand même des
difficultés on est dans un quartier
voilà c'est fini c'est pas forcément
facile pour tout le monde de se nourrir
surtout voilà que le confinement et puis
forcément beaucoup de travail donc les
gens ont un peu de mal au début c'était
vraiment de trois personnes qui étaient
vraiment la qualité est vraiment dans le
besoin on s'est dit pourquoi pas
développer ça pour plus de monde agnès
elle s'occupe des inscriptions et elle
voit bien le nombre de bénéficiaires
augmenter durant ce deuxième confinement
donc j'ai inscrit les personnes qui
viennent la semaine dernière on est à
130 familles dionysiennes aujourd'hui un
peu plus de 220 donc fernique qui
viennent pour la distribution du samedi
et de semaine en semaine avec les
inscriptions ça nous permet de voir le
nom de personne qui vient est
d'anticiper du coup les écoliers les
stocks pour mohamed l'un des fondateurs
de cette association
il est normal que les jeunes prennent
les choses en main mais ne lui dites pas
que c'est un héros du quotidien
pas de héros mais
on a un rôle à jouer permet nous les
jeunes du quartier et bal samedi on a du
temps libre
si on veut aider quelques familles ils
ne se prennent pas pour des héros mais
dans le quartie tous saluent leurs
engagements je suis contente que les
plus jeunes ils prennent la relève et
qui se décide à faire une sorte
d'association comme ça pour les gens qui
habitent autour d'eux parce que c'est
c'est généreux et c'est solidaire je
suis très fier des jeunes de la cité et
c'est qu'une bonne cité ici ce samedi
ces jeunes ont permis d'aider plus de
200 personnes en une seule matinée alors
que vous inspirent ces jeunes qu'on
vient d'entendre acquis qui aide ces
populations qui sont démunis vulnérables
et qui souffrent quelqu'un dit dans le
sujet ils ont faim mais moi je suis fier
je suis fier de ses jeunes parce que
c'est cette génération solidaire qui
face à des face à des difficultés face à
des problèmes en fait ils proposent des
solutions ils se saisissent et ils sont
acteurs de leur vie de leur territoire
et des jeunes comme ça j'en ai vu plein
en fait depuis mon entrée au
gouvernement puisque je me déplaçais
très largement avant le début du
confinement et j'en ai vu à rouen j'en
ai vu à guéret des jeunes qui face à une
difficulté ou face à un problème de
précarité et précarité alimentaire
eh bien ils ne baissent pas les droits
les bras au contraire et j'en ai gardé
en tête un sujet c'était à rouen jeu
j'oublierai jamais ce visage c'est un
jeune garçon était de 20 22 ans qui face
aux premiers confinement s'est rendu
compte que il avait faire on avait fermé
les restaurants universitaires et il y
avait toute une partie de nos étudiants
qui étaient qui n'arrivait plus à
acheter à manger ça a débloqué une
banque alimentaire dans un lacet de
l'amener à ce père avait on a beaucoup
lu ça et exactement et en fait ils ont
au début ils ont cuisiné et partager des
plats donc il est là ça me rappelait un
peu tous mes plats de famille léo qu'on
partage et puis se sont dit mais en fait
il ya beaucoup plus de monde beaucoup
plus de jeunes qui en ont besoin et pas
que ceux qui sont qui étaient identifiés
et là ils ont avec l'aide de la croix
rouge fait des paniers des paniers de
partage pour vraiment tous les étudiants
ne dit toujours que les étudiants sont
individualistes autocentré qui sont pas
engagés qui votent pas finalement il a
dû tout seul dans ce cas là alors je
vous assure pas du tout notre jeunesse
elle est extrêmement solidaire elle est
extrêmement engagée la seule différence
c'est qu'en fait ces engagements ne
ressemble pas aux engagements moi dire
traditionnel ce qu'on connaît c'est pas
parce qu'il ne rentre pas dans un
conseil d'ami
se rassemblent une association qu'ils ne
sont pas engagés dhainaut contraire les
groupes de quartier alors non c'est
souvent des quasiment des mots des
mobilisations de fait donc ça va être
une page facebook qui va se lancer et
qui va prendre en main ça va être une
association étudiante qui à la base est
plutôt culturelle peu importe l'objet
s'ils voient la nécessité d'intervenir
les interviennent c'est cette jeunesse
qui marche pour le climat c'est cette
jeunesse qui en fait face à n'importe
quelle difficulté va proposer des
solutions même si elles ne sont pas
classique même si elles ne sont elles
rentrent pas dans les cases et c'est ce
que j'ai vu c'est des jeunes qui créent
des applications avec des algorithmes
une jeunesse qui sait qu des maîtresses
et younes qui a du mal aussi parfois
s'en sortir le secours catholique nous
dit qu'il va y avoir 10 millions de
pauvres d'ici la fin de l'année
est ce que vous savez combien il ya de
jeunes dansaient 10 millions de pauvres
on a l'impression que eux aussi ils ont
du mal à manger
bien sûr il ne devenait c'est aussi
touchés par la précarité par la pauvreté
comme l'ensemble de notre pays par
contre là où c'est une priorité du
gouvernement c'est que elle est
accompagnée très spécifiquement et avec
un regard très particulier et là c'est
là où c'est quand j'y suis prêt au
dédoublement
c'est avec jean michel blanquer avec
frédéric vidal nous travaillons à
comment les accompagner au quotidien
comme on le fait très simplement avec
elisabeth bornes c'était le plan un
jeune une solution donc comment trouver
des solutions pour l'emploi comment
trouver des alternances comment pouvoir
s'engager avec un service civique c'est
6 5 milliards d'euros qui sont vraiment
que l attention de jeunesse mais ça
s'arrête pas là ça c'est pour trouver
des solutions trouver des chemins de
l'autre côté vous avez des êtres très
spécifique avec par exemple le versement
d'une aide exceptionnelle de 150 euros
là pour les exhorter à perdre par
exemple mais c'est les 150 euros pour
ceux qui touchent les appels ou les
étudiants boursiers c'est également les
repas un euro au restaurant
universitaire alors que le sait pas le
coût du repas qui coûte 1 euro c'est un
euro qui est donnée par l'étudiant pour
aussi voilà garder toute cette dignité
mais c'est aussi l'accompagnement
historique de toutes les associations de
l'alimentaire et ça c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment l'engagement le plus direct et
le plus fort du gouvernement
ces jeunes de l'association cette dream
l'un qui fait référence alors à leur
immeuble 10 mais on est très content de
faire ce boulot mais c'est à l'état de
le faire d'aider ces gens qui sont
démunis
qui sont vulnérables dans des quartiers
où le chômage de séville 1 30 40 % de
chômage chez les jeunes y a pas moyen de
transformer ces gestes d'engagement
bénévole en des petit job rémunéré
puisque il z la nation qui les a aidées
finalement en réalité ça s'appelle le
service civique ces cent mille mission
c'est plus de 563 millions d'euros qui
sont augmentés en tout ces cent mille
missions supplémentaires qui sont pros
qui sont proposés en l'occurrence c'est
cela ils sont hors service civique pour
rentrer mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas moyen
c'est à partir d'expériences qui existe
déjà de les transformer en job rémunéré
en réalité le bénévolat reste un
engagement gratuit
par contre ce que nous faisons c'est
comment on accompagne comment on
valorise le bénévolat donc ça va être
l'accompagnement dans les études quand
tu en études ça va être
comment reconnaît-on statut de bénévole
avec de la formation
mais le bénévolat c'est le bénévolat
donc il n'y a pas de rémunération à être
un engagé bénévoles par contre on peut
faire le choix de pouls de vivre un
engagement avec une indemnisation
parce qu'on souhaite un engagement long
dans le service de l'intérêt général et
la une des formes que ça peut prendre
c'est le service civique c'est quoi le
service civique c'est huit mois dans
l'intérêt général
donc dans une structure associative ou
dans le cadre d'une collectivité et
pendant huit mois
vous vivez une mission d'intérêt général
et c'est aujourd'hui la mission qui est
la mienne s'est accompagnée 240 mille
jeunes c'est à 240000 missions de
service civique possible et c'est de 16
ans à 30 ans donc trente ans si vous
êtes en situation de handicap 25 si vous
ne l'êtes pas mais c'est toute une
tout un chemin qui peut vous permettre
de faire de vivre un grand moment
d'engagement et en même temps de pouvoir
avoir une petite indemnité de vivre un
moment d'engagement plus long je reviens
sur ces jeunes qui galèrent finalement à
gauche beaucoup disent il faudrait un
rsa pour les jeunes les jeunes de moins
de 25 ans tu ta partir de 18 ans qu'est
ce que vous en pensez vous savez dans le
plan à un jeune une solution il y a des
réponses de 3 2 3 qui programment
famille veut pas entrer dans le détail
mais la première famille c'est comment
permettre un meilleur accès à l'emploi
donc c'est pour lutter contre le chômage
le chômage des jeunes avec toutes les
primes financières pour les entreprises
avec l'alternance différents différentes
pistes de le deuxième bloc est vraiment
sur la formation
c'est 200 me de formation dans les
métiers d'avenir c'est comment les
accompagner sur le numérique
comme les abris de transition
environnementale parce que c'est de ça
dont ils ont envie et puis une troisième
partie c'est ce qui m'amène à la
question du rsa jeunes qui est là pour
accompagner ceux qui sont le plus
fragiles et ceux qui sont dans la
difficulté ou la précarité est dedans il
ya deux grandes mesures
la première c'est 300 mille chemins
d'insertion donc c'est les gens qui sont
les jeunes qui sont les plus loin en
fait de l'emploi ou de la formation
et il est la garantie jeunes est en
réalité la garantie jeunes c'est mieux
que le rsa vous allez les tendres bien
sûr elle est déjà étendu aujourd'hui
dans le cadre de ce plan un jeune une
solution et le sait quoi la garantie
jeunes en quelques instants
c'est le rsa plus plus plus c'est
accessible dès 16 ans qui n'est pas le
ce qui n'est pas le cas de 16 à 25 ans
et c'est exactement la même somme que le
rsa par contre parce que vous êtes jeune
et que commencer sa vie avec un minima
social c'est quand même quelque chose de
bousculant et c'est parce que nous
souhaitons la garantie jeunes c'est
l'accompagnement humain de toute une
structure de d'accompagnants mais aussi
des temps collectifs
est ce que le pire pour un jeune si ce
n'est de répondre à l'urgence financière
se nourrir se loger se soigner pouvoir
se le peut voir avoir un toit c'est
également de trouver son chemin et donc
la garantie jeunes c'est permettre un
jeune entre 16 et 25 ans donc je couvre
la tout là toute la durée d'âge d'avoir
la petite indemnité qui lui permet quand
même de subvenir aux besoins premiers
parce que vous savez avec 545 150 euros
vous ne
on a du mal à suivre et on a du mal à
manger c'est le et c'est la valeur du
rsa donc c'est permettre quand même de
répondre à ces besoins premiers mais par
contre de s'en sortir est de trouver des
gens pour vous aider le pire c'est l'
isolement le pire c'est la solitude et
c'est de se dire à 16 ans 17 ans 18 ans
je n'ai aucun autre avenir que de
vilains minima social alors c'est pour
ça que je leur dis regardez la garantie
jeunes et d'ailleurs j'ai j'ai même
challenge est d'une certaine manière mon
administration puisque je les missionné
pour améliorer encore plus fortement et
encore plus parler parce que le plus dur
pour moi ça serait de croiser un jeune
qui en a besoin et qui ne sait pas que
ça existe vous dirais qu'on a une
génération sacrifiée aujourd'hui pas du
tout pas du tout parce que moi même
c'était crucial nommé même un petit peu
en colère parce que oui notre génération
est une génération qui est bousculé
parce que avoir 20 ans en 2020
c'est pas de voyage pas d'erasmus elle a
de grandes tapes est pas de plage macé
blu ray mais c'est pas sacrifier pour
autant parce qu'elle a une très grande
majorité de notre jeunesse
elle s'est saisie de cette difficulté
pour en faire des opportunités elle
trouve les solutions elle vit beaucoup
de moments de solidarité
moi j'ai plutôt on me dira avoir 20 ans
en 2020 c'est c'est appartenir à cette
génération solidaire plus qu'avant en
corps et en même temps il faut
reconnaître qu'elle est bousculée parce
que effectivement quand tu arrives en
première année de fac que tu n'as pas de
copains que tu ne connais pas la ville
que tu n'as pas eu ces grands moments de
rentrée qu'on est enfermé c'est pas
facile c'est vrai et je pense qu'on peut
le dire et ce n'est pas nier la réalité
parce que c'est des moments où tu as
beaucoup d'interactions sociales tu
étais là où tu toi tu te fais des
copains tu fais des fois des copains
pour la vie et en cette période
moi je leur dis vous savez ils sont
notre solution pour sortir de cette
morosité aussi sortir de cette crise
épidémique et donc leur direz vous et
hexa exactement engagez vous et vous
pouvez vous engager comme vous voulez
soit en allant par exemple sur le site
je veux aider point gouv.fr qu'il ya une
sorte de réserve citoyenne une réserve
civique à hauteur de pays ce n'est pas
le gouvernement pendant comptes inexacts
voyait juste pour l'anecdote sur les 300
mille inscrits et trois cent mille
inscrits sur au moment où premier
confinement plus de la moitié avait
moins de 25 ans c'est pas beau ça c'est
pas une belle génération d'engager ben
moi quand je vois ça je les tiens jean
genet et j'ai foi en l'avenir on est
tellement aller on va passer au dessert
à présent il me reste quelques minutes
c'est le péché mignon et on va parler de
votre dessert préféré à le gâteau
nantais qui est sous nos yeux très beau
gâteau glacé à un gâteau raffiné à base
d'amandes légèrement parfumée aux roms
et recouvert donc de ce fait un glaçage
au sucre alors ça vous savez faire aussi
le gâteau dans ta dit nous non je vous
avoue que je l'achète la mort je vais
être honnête je vais être honnête avec
vous c'est un gâteau c'est un gâteau qui
se partagent qu'ils gardent très bien
c'est pour ça que c'est pour ça que je
les aime beaucoup et puis c'est un
gâteau qui représente toute l'histoire
de mon territoire de chez moi c'est un
gâteau qui est tout à l'heure on disait
je suis le fruit de poids la de
plusieurs cultures de plusieurs de
plusieurs auteurs de plusieurs
territoires et bien ce gâteau il est à
l'image de tout ça parce que c'est
l'histoire de nantes avec ces anti
qui fait que le la vanille est arrivé
que leur homme est arrivé et on a fait
ce gâteau donc il ya plus de 100 ans ce
gâteau il est il était fait et la
première fois pour qu'ils tournent
longtemps lors des voyages et c'est pour
ça qu'à ce glaçage saissac à bon compte
en herbe en fait le moelleux à
l'intérieur garde le concert et puis qui
le protège effectivement parce que dure
que la pâte
il ya aussi des amendements qui sont
dans de nombreuses pâtisseries
marocaines je pense que c'est aussi ça
le met oui côté hybride de ceux de
servir totalement hybride est totalement
généraux enfin c'est super bon et
délicieux en plus de son bien l'europe
et d'ailleurs le rhum et partout où on
fait des fois on imagine qu'il est que
dans le code en la tenant il est
vraiment partout ils étaient imbibés de
rome et il me semble on sent très
largement la veille en bas il ya
beaucoup de monde
ouais bah tu le dis les prendre tous les
ingrédients là aussi nous qui sommes
très sur les poncifs et les idées reçues
on s'attendait à déguster des baklavas
vous préférez part de gâteau que ces
gâteaux plein de miel plein blur c'est
pâteuse et pâtisseries marocaines qui
sont formidables qui sont souvent
j'adore et en traquant de gazole les
cornes de gazelle les afghans de gazelle
avec un avec un thé à la menthe
évidemment après moi je mon dessert
préféré préférées il ya le gâteau nantes
et qu'on garde toute la semaine j'adore
les tartes tatin on en a parlé tout à
l'heure mais une tarte tatin avec une
bonne glace à la vanille franchement
c'est à tomber sur le caramel isérois se
trompent et pour l'anecdote sur le
chocolat
quand j'ai grandi dans des restaurants
et mon premier stage de 3e je le fais je
vais dans un restaurant et hydratant
nous parents en boucle mais tant attendu
où il met en pâtissent commis en
pâtisserie et donc quand on faisait des
mini on faisait les petites pâtisseries
et dont une s'était le mini fondant
chocolat
sauf qu'au bout de deux jours je fais
une crise de foi parce qu'en fait un
chèque mais savait réussir le coeur
coulant milieu oui avec des petites des
affaires plus maintenant je m'amuse
puisque les corps coulant on peut on
peut s'amuser à mettre un peu de caramel
au beurre salé
on peut mettre un peu de chocolat au
lait alors c'est pas c'est pas le
fondant classique mais on peut s'amuser
avec les fruits rouges aussi j'aime
beaucoup les pâtisseries ou caramel
aussi les caramels aux personnes âgées
des caramels d'ailleurs alors pendant le
confinement c'est pas toujours facile de
voir la vie en rose certains sont dans
des appartements exigus
on peut sortir une heure par jour alors
on a décidé de vous redonner un peu la
banane
sarah elle rit je vous connais depuis
2010 est depuis que vous êtes député ici
à l'assemblée et vous avez toujours la
banane c'est quoi votre secret je suis
quelqu'un de profondément optimiste
parce que parce que je crois que on a un
chemin pour chacun et que quand tu es
solidaire quand tu veux quand tu veux
quand tu partages un peu d'énergie
positive même dans les moments les plus
difficiles
alors tu trouves en toi cette énergie et
j'avoue que quand j'ai un vagin petit
coup de mou je vais manger typiquement
une rigole est que j'ai ramené avec moi
parce que c'est un autre petit pêché un
petit cadeau fait exactement c'est un
petit cadeau donc c'est des bonbons qui
sont en fait croquant à l'extérieur et
répondant à l'intérieur c'est ces
nantais c'est c'est sucré c'est fruité
mais surtout d'achat c'est exactement ça
chasse à ce que le nom évoque la
rigolade donc on se dit tiens c'est bon
pour le et et j'aime laisser comme le
gâteau nantais comme les rigoles est
j'aime ces produits qui peuvent rester
longtemps à la maison et qu'ils ne se
perdent pas et en réalité un gâteau
nantais vous pouvez le garder bien une
semaine sans problème ça reste très très
moelleux même si on l'a commencée une
rigolade ça peut rester un ou deux mois
sans problème dans son bureau
donc pour garder la banane un peu
l'alimentation et aussi le sport ou
d'autres choses un peu de lecture
beaucoup quand même de produits à manger
et la cuisine et j'avoue et un peu de
lecture et puis un peu de télé ces
derniers temps cardinal de mazarin
c'est un livre que vous êtes en train de
dire c'est ça le bréviaire les
politiciens oui il m'a pas ce qu'on fait
c'est hyper rigolo à l'intérieur mais
c'est vrai j'ai vu comme ça non car
position mais c'est pour ça je me suis
dit il faut casser faut casser les codes
vous invite à le regarder
c'est comme quoi l'histoire c'est quand
on sait d'où on vient on sait où on peut
aller et donc le pré vert du pôle its a
donc un cardinal mazarin
c'est plein de petits stratagèmes plein
de petites histoires et c'est plein de
le résumer c'est simule dissimule ne te
fier à personne dit du bien tout le
monde prévoit avant d'agir c'est un peu
le milieu dans lequel vous évoluez en
politique c'est très amusant réalité si
vous prenez un peu de hauteur vous
prenez passé au sérieux je vous invite à
lire et en fait j'ai de livres
le bréviaire je peux relire dopage le
poser sur sa table de chevet rompre en
ressasse effectivement c'est pas un
thriller où la houle intrigue risque de
ses fils louis saha se prête ça revient
vous ouvrez au milieu ça se lit très
bien il ya un autre livre que je en
train de dire mais parce que j'ai
rencontré son auteur c'est le nénuphar
mais c'est martin hirsch qui l'a écrit
et c'était des brefs messages de les ré
ouvert avec le 2ème confinement parce
qu'il avait écrit lors du premier
confinement des petits bouts de ces
journées et c'est assez facile assez
facile à lire et c'est en même temps
très très poignant on va écouter ça
maintenant si vous voulez bien c'est ce
que c'est
[Musique]
audi porte ou vous reconnaissez
manhattan qu'est notre manhattan kaboul
axelle red acceptons la confusion parce
que c'est pas tout jeunes comme comme tu
veux et je suis obligé de vous avouer
qu'à chaque fois que j'allume ma
plateforme musicale sur mon téléphone
c'est pour ça que je commence pourquoi
vous aimez cette chanson allez zurin
parce qu'elle a été écrite après les
attentats du 11 septembre
elle l'a elle dit beaucoup elle est dure
mais l'est elle est très belle parce
qu'en fait elle nous renvoie notre
humanité et que tu sois petit
portoricain ou au fin fond d'un pays du
moyen-orient victimes du terrorisme où
un jeune français de creuse de loire
atlantique ou d'alsace quel que soit
l'endroit où tu es quelle que soit la
famille dans laquelle tu vis tu es tu as
une petite lumière d'humanité et je
crois que ce message d'universalité moi
me touche et me plaît et quant à un
moment de chagrin ou une journée un peu
difficile et que tu réécoutes cette
chanson tu dit dans le fond allez ça va
aller parce qu'il ya des moments
beaucoup plus grave et plus dur dans
dans la vie par contre qu'il faut pas
oublier c'est que tous les gens que tu
croises quelle que soit la raison dans
ta vie d'engager dans ta vie politique
ou dans ta vie de tous les jours cd
c'est des êtres humains c'est des gens
qui ont une vie qui ont des parents qui
ont des cellules manie sme qui vous
caractérise vraiment bien ça fait du
bien
merci d'avoir partagé ce déjeuner avec
nous merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis merci à chez françoise qui nous a
cuisiné tous ces plats on vous retrouve
bien sûr la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de politique à table
[Musique]